Halloween Time takes over the Disneyland Resort...
...each year throughout September and October.
Favorite attractions offer spooky enhancements during this time...
...such as a frightfully fun for all ages takeover of the Haunted Mansion by Jack Skellington.
Inspired by the classic animated film, Tim Burton's "Nightmare Before Christmas,"...
...this transformation is a collision of Halloween creepiness and Christmas cheer.
Space Mountain also gets a ghoulish makeover...
...with ghosts appearing out of the starry darkness.
Exhilarating drops and turns are punctuated by piercing screams,...
...spine-chilling sound effects and haunting music.
The Twilight Zone Tower of Terror will also take you on a terrifying trip.
And if you drop in soon,...
...you can even experience this attraction like never before in complete darkness.
Other Halloween activities can be found throughout Disneyland Resort...
...including the special after-hours Mickey's Halloween Party,...
...which includes themed fireworks,...
...a sighting of the Headless Horseman galloping through the park...
...and chances to party like a villain all through the night.